YASMINE MEHDI
- L'accès à Fort Myers reste
très difficile aujourd'hui.
On se trouve devant le pont
qui relie la ville à la plage
et qui est fermé depuis
ce matin, à part pour
les résidents et les premiers
répondants. Donc les conditionss
ici, avec une connexion
cellulaire hasardeuse,
des milliers de personnes qui
sont toujours privées de courant
et des Floridiens qui cherchent
désespérément de la nourriture,
de l'eau potable ou
de l'essence. Et pendant
que les résidents de Fort Myers
commencent à prendre
connaissance de l'ampleur
des dégâts, il yforts
de l'extérieur de la Floride qui
viennent prêter main-forte pour
évacuer les secteurs les plus
isolés, comme Pine Island
el, qui sont coupés
du monde depuis mercredi et
seulement accessibles par avion
ou par bateau. Évidemment
certains s'inquiètent de voir
le bilan s'alourdir encore plus,
alors que les recherches
se poursuivent et que
les hélicoptères survolent
le secteur. Et pendant ce temps,
d'autres résidents à qui on a
parlé eux, sont encore sous
le choc de découvrir leur
communauté complètement
défigurée et de voir l'ampleur
des dommages. Je vous laisse
écouter des réactions qu'on a
recueillies aujourd'hui.
Le président américain Joe Biden
et la première dame Jill Biden
sont attendus ici mercredi,
pour conis
l'ampleur des dégâts. Avant ça,
ils vont s'arrêter à Porto Rico
demain. Porto Rico qui a été
durement touché par l'ouragan
Fiona la semaine d
Donc on parle de dégâts chiffrén
sait que la reconstruction sera
longue et prendra peut-être
même des années.
mine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, à Fort Myers,
en Flor